what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and right now fans are freaking out in
excitement over the fact that we could
possibly be getting a Thor five
relatively soon in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe while Tao ATI was talking about
Thor 5 in the Thor love and thunder the
official movie special book not only did
he confirm that he already has plans for
another movie but in this book he
actually goes into some details about
what he would do for the next Thor film
essentially giving us some plot details
for Thor 5 now another Thor film comes
at little to no surprise considering the
fact that Thor love and thunder post
credit scene set up Hercules to go out
and take on Thor the love of Thunder
because he attacked his father Zeus so a
lot of us would assume that the next
movie is going to be about Hercules Thor
fighting Hercules however I don't think
this is really what the story is going
to be about but luckily for us Tao atiti
does talk about what he would have Thor
five be about and it kind of involves
some aliens according to Tao ATI but of
course if this is going to be coming out
before Avengers the King Dynasty or
before Avengers Secret Wars it's going
to also have to tie into Kang somehow
plus we hear from Chris Hemsworth and
what he has recently said about his
thoughts on a new Thor movie what he
feels on whether or not he should
continue to Play Thor or not and how
long he thinks it would be appropriate
to continue to play the character and of
course we'll break down everything you
need to know in this video and be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest MCU news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
so just as this news about Thor 5 broke
out the other day coming from the
official Thor love and thunder the
official movie special book we hear from
Tao atiti in that same book and like I
mentioned he tells us what he would do
if given the opportunity to direct
another Thor film and based off of what
we've heard what it sounds like taoa
Titi probably is going to be the
director of the next Thor movie despite
what some of the fans out there want but
we'll get to that in a bit but here's
what he says about what Thor five could
be about and then we'll talk about what
Chris Hemsworth says as well in the book
when speaking about Thor 5 he said this
what is left to do to him it's got to be
something that feels like it's carrying
on with the evolution of the character
but still in a very fun way and still
giving him things to come up against
that feel like they're building on the
obstacles that he has to overcome I
don't think we can have a villain that's
weaker than Hela I feel like we need to
step up from there and add a villain
that's somehow more formidable okay
let's pause right here before we finish
what Tao atiti says in this book we
talked about this a little bit before of
course you need somebody that is
stronger than Hela and you need somebody
that is stronger than Gore as well since
that was a lost villain and there's a
lot of characters that you could put
Thor up against right now but I think
the perfect character that Thor could go
up against in Thor five is Beta Ray Bill
at first at least and let me explain if
you make Thor five primarily about Beta
Ray Bill that will bring fans to the
theaters that will get fans super
excited that is what we've been waiting
for for four films now and in Thor
Ragnarok we saw the statue of betel or
another corbon night at least it was
definitely a corbon night and we assume
it's betay Bill and then in Avengers
ingame the directors did confirm that
the planet that nebula and gamorra were
on was Corbin the home world of the
Corbin nightes where Beta Ray Bill is
from so we've gotten close but haven't
actually had that Beta Ray Bill debut
and I think a lot of fans would love to
see him fight alongside Thor in Avengers
Secret Wars against Kang who I think
should be the true villain of Thor 5
unless Marvel Studios has had plans for
Thor 5 to come out before Avengers King
Dynasty and we just don't know about it
I don't think it's coming out before
then they have way too many projects
coming out before Avengers King Dynasty
and I think right now their priority is
getting Dr strange 3 out before that
movie however there is plenty of time
for Thor 5 to come out before Avengers
Secret Wars which means they should find
a pretty good way for them to tie into
the secret War storyline and Thor is one
of the OG Avengers one of the last ones
standing in the MCU still so I would
love for him to have a major role in
Avengers Secret Wars because if Thor 5
comes out before then this could be the
last time we see Chris himsworth Play
Thor in the Marvel Cinematic Universe he
could retire the character and
especially if Marvel Studios is planning
on rebooting the MCU whether a hard
reboot or a soft reboot that could mean
the end of Chris Hemsworth's career
playing Thor and based off of some
things that he said about playing Thor
which we'll get into in a bit it seems
like it's definitely a possibility that
Thor 5 could be his last time as Thor
and if that is true then there should be
a new Thor in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and Beta Ray Bill would be
perfect fans would love to see Thor and
Beta Ray Bill go at it in the comics
Beta Ray Bill actually defeats Thor
originally and that's how he gets a
hammer from Odin so he is definitely a
formidable adversary and they could
easily work this into the story Zeus
might not just send Hercules he could
also send other people and badab Bill
might be another one of those people
that he sends after Thor but as I've
mentioned before badia Bill and Hercules
eventually become good friends with Thor
and they are not enemies I believe the
same thing will probably happen in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now let's
continue breaking down what taica said
he said along with the new foe what Titi
said that he also wants to introduce
more and more outlandish and crazy
beasts Monsters and Aliens and he wants
to introduce these from various worlds
that remain true to the Thunder God's
mythological Origins and that's really
cool I would actually really enjoy that
adding a Norse mythology side to the
actual movies would be super super
interesting to see since that is indeed
what Thor and Odin and Loki are based
off of Norse mythology but he continued
to State there's a fun element to Thor
and he has a casualness and a sort of
swagger about about him when he visits
these worlds and encounters these aliens
that I don't think you'd get when it's
an Earthling traveling through space
exploring the universe and these are the
adventures that taoa Titi wants to
explore in the next Thor film Thor going
to different worlds encountering
different creatures different aliens and
kind of not being phased because he's
the god of thunder and he's visited many
worlds and seen many different types of
species in the past but if he has to tie
it into Avengers Secret Wars then I'm
assuming he's going to come across a
king variant and that could ultimately
end up being the big bad of the film I
think Marvel Studios might go with a
common theme of having Kang or variant
of Kang pop up in these solo films and
having the individual Avengers like Thor
and Doctor Strange kind of lose to Kang
in their own film and that sets up
Avengers Secret Wars or Avengers King
Dynasty depending on where these movies
take place on the timeline because like
I've mentioned before I think the
Avengers are going to lose to Kang in
Kang Dynasty sort of like they lost the
Thanos in Avengers Infinity war and then
of course Secret Wars is going going to
be about restoring what has been broken
in Infinity war and endgame it was half
the universe but in Avengers Secret Wars
it's going to be about the entire
Multiverse and I think that some
individual Avengers might lose to Kang
before Secret Wars as well so I would
love to see bet Ray Bill and Kang the
Conqueror in Thor 5 now as far as Chris
Hemsworth continuing to Play Thor here's
what he had to say about his future and
the character this was in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly where he said
I don't want to continue to do it until
people are so exhausted that they roll
their eyes when they see me come on the
screen as that character if an audience
wants to see it and if there's something
that we believe is exciting and fun then
great I loved being able to reinvent
that character a few times I don't have
the answer yet but I would love to try
and figure out how we can do that again
and keep it a little unpredictable so
Chris Hemsworth is down to continue to
Play Thor if they can have the character
grow and be a little bit unpredictable
and I think that would end up requiring
a pretty big change from Thor love and
thunder and Chris Hemsworth said that
even in another interview that there
would have to be a change in tone for
the character meaning he'd have to be a
little bit more serious and if Tao ATI
wants to lean more into the Norse
mythology and if Kang the Conqueror is
going to be involved and the threat of
the Multiverse is going to be involved
then I'm definitely thinking that Chris
Hemsworth is coming back for Thor 5 will
he return for another film after that
especially after he does Thor five and
then Secret Wars who knows but it
definitely does seem like we are in for
a bit of a change with Thor 5 from Thor
love and thunder which I think fans will
really enjoy because a lot of fans did
complain about Thor love Thunder being a
little bit too silly but it sounds like
Chris Hemsworth will probably only
return if the next film isn't as silly
as Thor 11 Thunder and based off of the
condition of the MCU right now how
serious of a threat Kang and his
variants are in the Multiverse falling
apart it seems like no matter what
happens it should be pretty serious and
I think Chris Hemsworth understands that
and I'm sure Tao would teach understands
that as well so I would fully expect
Thor 5 when we get that film to be very
different tonally like Chris himsworth
wanted and to be a lot more serious
while at the same time exploring more
Norr mythology and going to visit other
alien planets which could be extremely
interesting but let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below do you think this would be a good
plot for Thor five beta R Bill showing
up in fighting him and fighting Hercules
but then Kang being the main villain or
do you think they should go another
route let us know all your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
subscribe to the channel so you don't
miss out on any of the latest MCU news
and so you can enter our giveaway don't
forget to like the video and follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof